μπορεί να σημαίνει οι συνδικαλιστικές οργανώσεις θα σεβαστό πλήρος στην άλλη να αποψη αν είναι
τεκμηριωμένι και βεβαίως θα αλλάξω και τη δική μου έναν έχω εγώ λάθος φτάνει όμως
να είναι δεκμηριωμένοι αλλι άποψη και να μη γίνεται απλά για αντι παράθεση η απλά
γιασκοπούς μικροπολιτικής μετανιώσατε ποτ επόβατευτικά την προτάση το λίγου χριστατουλίδα κοιτάξεται ήταν μια μεγάλη αποφασιγιαμένα
γιατί δεν είχα κάν συμπληρώσει τα χρόνια μου ενώ για να πάρω της σύνταξη μου
ήμουν μια ζωή τεχνοκράτης μια ζωή στο δημόσιο δι ευθύνρια του παιδαγωγικού ενστητού του γιαδέκα
χρόνια την πήρα όμως θυνηδητά του την την απόφαση γιατί υπα ότι φτάνει πια πρέπει
να κάνουμε πράγματα για το εκπαιδευτικό σύστημα έχουμε φτάσει των πάτο είναι πολύ σημαντικό αυτό
να το λέει η διαυπουργός έχουμε φτάσει σε ένα σημείων που χρειάζεται να πάμε προς
τα πάνω το αξίζον τα παιδιά μας έχουμεν εξαρετικού μαθητές και ματήτριες δημόσειο σχολείον πάρα
πολύ καλό εκπαιδευτικούς στην πλιοψηφίατους πολύ καλους τους οποίο κοτώνουμε με τις πολιτικές μας άρα
πρέπει να αλλάξουμε πολιτικές να κάμουμε στροφη να πάμε μπρος το σύγχρονο σχολείον κα ναι
αυτό που βαλέύουμε αρά όχι δεν έχομετανιώσι έχω πάρα πολύνό ορεξη να κάμωπράγματα με τη
στήριξη και των συνεργατό μας μπορούμε να φέρουμε την αλλαγή που θέλουμε και το μεγαλύτερο
στίχημα ρώτησαν τη μεγαλύτετη δυσκολία το μεγαλύτερο στίχημα πρίφι γιαί από τα υπουργειο παιδιας και
είναι για την αφναμιχαλθα είμαι ιδιαίτερα ικανοποιημένοι αν καταφέρουμε να αλλάξουμε την καρδιά αναγγίξουμε την
καρδιά του προβληγμαδώς που είναι το τίτη δάσκουμε το περιεχόμενο για πολλά χρόνια ξέρεται επικεντροθεήκαμε
στην απόμνημόνευση την αποστήθηση ο καλώς μαθητής στο σχολείο δεν είναι ο εξυπνοσμαθη της πια
δεν είναι όμαθητίσμε το δημιουργικό μιαλόν και την κενοτομία αντι δημιουργικόταν την κριτική σκέψηεναι αυτός
που μπορεί να μάθει απε έξω κάποιες σελίδες α